welcome everybody hope
everybody had a good weekend it was
certainly a very busy weekend of news
and we're going to go over
a bunch of it today of course the big
news is that donald trump appears to be
rapidly on his path to getting impeached
a second time
and this will make donald trump the only
president in history
to be impeached two times so we're going
to talk about that but the timing of it
seems to be
uh that the house may impeach as soon as
wednesday morning
scheduling a vote for wednesday morning
and there will be debate tomorrow
we may cover the debate tomorrow
and then we may cover the vote on
wednesday morning we will see
uh there is also concern about possible
once again violence as the vote is going
on
in washington d.c and now uh we'll be
covering it later this
week but security beefed up and of
course we're still wondering what the
hell happened last wednesday but
security reportedly beefed up
um around the capitol and we are seeing
more and more um people arrested
as a result of what took place last week
and we're going to talk about that i
have nancy pelosi's interview with 60
minutes which contains some good
and some bad and some very very bad
i also have a new exclusive song
with quite a bit of toilet humor and it
feels almost like it's a little bit
beneath the show
but it's also quite funny so i i may
play it for you
um and there are just so many different
things so many different different
things going on
um and there are vid yeah there's no fly
videos where some of the rioters are
being told
as they arrive at airports that they've
been put on a no-fly list
as a result of their excuse me
participation in the riotous
insurrection
and they go bananas uh
there's just so much there's so much
going on so i i mean listen
let's just get into it i know people are
still coming in and welcome to everybody
by the way
on youtube twitch and facebook it's all
wild what is going on let's just get
into it the big news of course trump's
getting impeached again let's take a
listen
doesn't act today house democrats will
proceed with impeachment the single
article of impeachment they have
introduced says quote
donald john trump engaged in high crimes
and misdemeanors by inciting violence
against the government of the united
states
he also willfully made statements that
in context encouraged and foreseeably
resulted in
lawless action at the capitol we could
be seeing a vote on that here in the
coming days
bring it right to the floor and it will
be
considered by the full house and i
expect that he will be impeached he will
be the
the first president in history to be
impeached twice right
we need to make it clear and then let me
just skip ahead to the report from
uh jim acosta about what is going on
hold on wherein this is the uh here it
is
here's the latest on that of his soapbox
we are though hearing from white house
insiders
let's check in with cnn chief white
house correspondent jim acosta on that i
mean what is happening behind the scenes
here jim
it seems like not much of anything well
the president isn't hiding he is behind
closed doors he is not coming out in
front of the cameras
and white house aides are not anxious or
eager to get him out in front of the
cameras
frankly they don't know what he's going
to do next and that's also what we're
hearing
from advisers to this white house at
this point the president has
shown no sign of remorse that he feels
bad at all or apologetic at all about
the events that happened on
january 6th even though he should uh
feel that way he should feel some sense
of remorse but this is the
take no responsibility president he's
been this way since day one brianna
you know that all too well he's not he's
not going to change his stripes in that
regard
now as for what phil mattingly was
talking about in terms of the 25th
amendment a few moments ago
uh we do know from talking to our
sources over here that vice president
mike pence is keeping that on the table
as an
option interesting as a way to sort of
say to the president listen if you get
out of line and do something
uh insane one more time this 25th
amendment is a live
option uh whether or not the vice
president would actually
try to invoke that or attempt to invoke
that that remains to be seen
and reportedly pence and trump haven't
even spoken since the insurrection
but they are sort of using that as a
kind of a carrot and stick with the
president
uh at this pro at this point is that is
my sense of it at this point brianna
now in terms of the president uh he and
his top aides they want to
try to go out with some semblance of i
guess whatever
dignity they have left uh they are
planning a whole slew of
events throughout this week he's going
to go down to the border tomorrow to
talk about the border wall
uh and try to highlight that even though
it's a promise broken he used taxpayer
money to build
uh portions of the wall on the border he
did not have mexico pay for the wall
and he wants to point to what you know
other things that they consider to be
deemed to be accomplished
uh accomplishments over here uh but at
this point no sign whether or not as you
were just mentioning a few moments ago
brianna
whether or not the president will come
into the briefing room whether or not
yeah so we met we may not see trump
again although there is a scheduled
propaganda
event tomorrow at the u.s mexico border
uh if it if it happens
i will cover it for you live we are not
expecting donald trump to take any
questions there whatsoever
uh because as you can imagine um he
uh would immediately be asked about
things he doesn't want to talk about
okay so so that's
that's very very unlikely that we are
going to see that okay a few super chats
i thought the senate blocked the last
impeachment no
trump was impeached which happens in the
house and the senate voted not to
convict that's not blocking impeachment
it's they voted not to convict
uh relizior de nova says hi david i'd
love for you to butcher my name please
well
yeah maybe i just did i'm not i'm not
really sure
uh jacob ratner says is the storming of
the capital a black swan
event i that's a good question black
swans are
uh that's the phrase used by nasim talib
in his book the black swan and i don't
know sometimes you don't know if
something is a black swan event until
it's in the rearview mirror
and i think we we simply don't know yet
um oh and fiona says looking handsome
tonight david still got our fingers
crossed for that only fans account with
hope and love
from london wow that's pretty strong
that's uh
if there's ever been any any strong
inducement to create and only fans it's
probably that
okay so remember that the premise as of
this morning was
if they can't move forward with the 25th
amendment on trump
democrats will impeach house republicans
blocked consideration of a bill today to
consider the 25th amendment
here was that earlier today
the chair lays before the house a
communication
the honorable the speaker house of
representatives madam
i hereby submit my resignation as
sergeant-at-arms of the u.s house of
representatives
it has been an honor to serve signed
very respectfully
paul d irving sergeant-at-arms so
there's the sergeant-at-arms resigning
over the failures last week
without objection the resignation is
accepted
pursuant to the provisions of section
208
a of the legislative reorganization act
of 1946 the chair appoints timothy
paul blodgett of the state of new york
it's actually further in
let's get past this here we go house
resolution 22
resolution electing a member to a
certain standing committee of the house
of representatives
without objection the resolution is
adapted and a motion to reconsider
i think it's the next resolution 23
resolution electing a member to a
certain standing committee of the house
of representatives
without objection for what purpose here
we go the gentleman from maryland
seek recognition madam speaker i ask
unanimous consent if the committee on
the judiciary
be discharged from further consideration
of hres
21 and asked for its immediate
consideration in the house
the clerk will report the title of the
resolution
house resolution 21 resolution calling
on vice president michael r pence to
convene and mobilize
the principal officers of the executive
departments of the cabinet to activate
section 4
of the 25th amendment to declare
president donald j trump
incapable of executing his office
right and to immediately exercise powers
as acting president who could deny that
for what purpose does the gentleman from
west virginia rise
i object objection is heard
pursuant to section 5 a 1 b of the house
resolution
8 the house stands adjourned to 9 00 a.m
tomorrow okay so that came and went very
quickly 25th amendment uh moving on
beyond that
and uh we are now uh moving into the
impeachment phase which will start
tomorrow with debate
and then presumably a vote on impeaching
donald trump in the house as early as
wednesday so we are going to be covering
that
and uh we will we will follow follow
that up i do want to talk about parlor
i'm going to talk about that momentarily
now i i think it it bears mentioning and
there's people
sending me super chats about this fbi
memo warns law enforcement across the
u.s of possible armed protests at 50
state capitals yeah
let's even pull that up um we have a
segment coming up tomorrow
uh let's see if we can get hold on a
second i guess i have to shut off ad
blocker
on this particular page continue
let's see where that uh hold on nbc news
fb here it is okay fbi memo warns law
enforcement
across 50 wow it's like i oh my god
without an ad blocker it's unusable
fbi memo warns law enforcement across
the us if possible armed protests at 50
state capitals the fbi also says an
armed group has threatened to travel to
washington and stage an uprising if
congress removes donald trump from
office the fbi has sent a memo to law
enforcement agencies across the country
warning of possible
armed protests at all 50 state capitals
starting january 16 and also says an
armed group has threatened to travel to
d.c
the same day and stage an uprising if
congress removes president trump from
office
according to a senior law enforcement
official the memo includes information
provided by the atf dea
defense department park police and the
u.s marshals among other agencies
some of the information came from social
media some from open source
and some from other sources of
information
the senior law enforcement official says
the fbi's national crisis coordination
center distributed the update to law
enforcement agencies
as a summary of threat information
they've received following last
wednesday's deadly mob attack on the
capitol
while the memo discusses possible
threats discussed by online actors for
the 16th through the 20th
it doesn't mean law enforcement agencies
expect violent mass
protests in every state for instance a
spokesperson for the fbi in boston says
at this point in time fbi boston is not
in possession of intelligence indicating
any planned armed protests
at the four state capitals in our area
of responsibility maine
massachusetts new hampshire and rhode
island
so here's the bottom line as i
understand it right now
it is almost a guarantee
that there will be more violent protests
between now and january 20th
where they are going to be and when they
are going to take
place is an open question and the answer
could be all of the above
we we just don't know and uh that that
is my belief
and beyond that i i don't know that it's
too
too clear right now what it is that we
are expecting to see
let's get now to the battle over parlor
i have a lot to say about what's going
on with parlor parlors the right wing
social media app
which has been where lots of right
wingers saw
safe harbor after twitter and facebook
abandoned donald trump but now we are
seeing google apple and amazon ban
parlor from app stores and from using
amazon hosting services
and it's it's almost funny it's
almost funny the degree to which they
are misstating what is taking place
let's listen to devin nunes briefly
and then i'll tell you my thoughts on it
that
there is no longer a free and open
social media company or site for any
american to get on
any longer so first and foremost what
is not uh any what there isn't is
a rule that says to amazon you have to
host
parlor parlor still exists
okay uh what we are seeing is the free
market
this is capitalism it is capitalism
for facebook to say we are going to make
a business decision
it is capitalism for google to say
we are going to remove parlor from the
app store the alternative
would be government telling these
businesses how they must operate
republicans have been against that for
decade after decade
because these big companies apple
amazon google they have just destroyed a
what was likely parlor is likely a
billion dollar company
i don't know that that's true but okay
poof it's gone
but it's more than just the financial
aspect to that
republicans have no way to communicate
have you heard of email they have no way
to communicate what
if it doesn't even matter if you're a
republican or conservative if you
don't want to be regulated by left
wingers
that are at twitter and facebook and
instagram where you get shadow band
nobody gets to see you
nobody gets to see you they get to
decide what's violent or not violent
it's preposterous so i don't know
where the hell the department of justice
is at right now or the oh that's rich
listen these people
have been arguing for 20 years
let's not go and enforce the antitrust
laws that are on the books i have
interviews with antitrust experts on my
show
these are the people who have been
saying no no no we don't and we don't
leftist liberals like liz warren want to
deal with antitrust we don't
that's them now these tech companies are
huge
and now they say well listen somehow
these companies got so big
and they're sort of like town squares
now and we need to regulate them
they've been saying for 20 years
businesses shouldn't be regulated the
free market will regulate them if a
business makes a decision
that the people don't like the people
will vote with their dollars
where are they now so it's not just that
they're hypocrites
they're the reason we have the lack of
regulatory infrastructure that they now
claim to want
they're the reason we've not dealt with
the monopolistic
behavior of these firms all along
and now all of a sudden they say oh my
god what do you mean
listen google says no but you can still
get parlor
in a different way parlor could get
their own servers and you could download
the app
yeah but google's so big now well why
why did google get so big
because when liz warren was saying we've
got to break up these tech monopolies
you were saying no you were saying we're
for free enterprise
you so capitalism is destroying parlor
the free market is destroying parlor
that's it
and uh we're going to have more coverage
of this tomorrow
let's just listen to a little more of
this screed uh this is
clearly a violation of antitrust
oh and i i didn't i haven't even
pre-watched this
he was the one saying his party is the
party of let's not worry about antitrust
can you imagine here we go
civil rights the rico statute
so by the way civil rights um
if amazon was saying we are going to put
in some policy that will discriminate
against
you know black owned apps or
christian owned apps political
affiliation is not a protected i believe
in dc it is
but nationally political at other in
other states political affiliation is
not a protected class
businesses everywhere other than dc and
fact check me
businesses anywhere from dc they're not
allowed to say
we don't serve black people they're not
allowed to say
we don't serve jewish people they're not
allowed to say
we don't serve people who are from
thailand but they are allowed to say
we don't serve republicans if if they so
want because political orientation
is not a protected class and now he he's
talking about civil rights now
there should be a racketeering
investigation on all
the people that coordinated this attack
on not only a company
it's uh if i just played for you
there should be something happening to
people who coordinated this attack
you would imagine he's talking about
about the attack on the capitol by
trumpists
he's talking about a so-called attack on
parlor
imagine but on all of those
like us like me like you maria i have
three million followers on par
[Laughter]
oh no parlor uh tonight
i will no longer be able to communicate
with those people
and they're americans and by the way
unlike the fake
social media sites we know that
everybody that's on parlor because you
get why isn't he from california why
does he have a southern accent
or is that required to be like playing
his role certified there's a number it's
actually very a very very safe platform
and if you break the law on parlor
the fbi can subpoena to get to find out
who those people
are what is he talking about if you
break crimes on facebook and twitter
good luck good luck trying to find out
who they are so parlors went above and
beyond it's one of the
reasons why i didn't go to parlor you
know eight months ago because
it was a republican platform i didn't
know if it was republican or not
that's that's such bs can you he had no
it might have been a super liberal
platform he didn't know
i went there because i knew that i could
express my
thoughts freely and that i knew that my
that
the
the list as i post something was going
to be there and so this guy's disgusting
so basically he wants the government to
restrict the free speech of corporations
is what it sounds like very heavy-handed
republican
very very heavy-handed republican that's
uh that's for sure okay
let me let me get caught up with with
some of the things that are going on
here
i do want to say thank you to the six
really great people who just grabbed
subs on twitch
i very much appreciate that also a big
thank you to
diana dapsevich who signed up at
joinedpakman.com
alexander froderberg
matthew sadler rochelle
cove and myrtle dawes that's one two
three four
five uh putting this at eleven i very
much appreciate that
uh and joinedpakman.com very very
strongly working right now it couldn't
be working any better
let me look at a few super chats what is
twitter saying
i i'm not sure i'm not sure what you
mean a lot of right leading californians
take a fake southern accent for some
reason i thought it was weird
a disgruntled employee at the state
department changed the biography of
trump and pence to say their term ended
on monday i saw that
did you know about someone getting all
parlor's user information because it
turns out their security wasn't great i
did see that
someone archived the posts on parlor
act sign signed this is over jail time
biden
um is this someone who thinks biden's
going to jail is that what's going on in
my stream that's crazy
billion dollar company parlor is in
hendersonville nevada and employs 15
people their app security was running on
free trial software
if that's true that's funny thoughts on
parlor post being archived on cloud yeah
i don't know enough about it yet to say
social apps aren't a civil right yeah i
had a tweet about this yesterday
uh where was this oh by the way
so this is just this is every day you're
a [ __ ] and a liar i guess i'm lying
on the ground
my my a [ __ ] and i'm lying on the
ground
is how i would interpret this message
anyway that's not what i was trying to
get
uh to what i was trying to get to was
this all americans have an unalienable
right to twitter and any limitation on
access is an unconstitutional violation
of rights granted by god
also americans don't have a right to
health care that's a product to be
bought and sold on the free market
for those who can afford it so that
that's that's where people like devin
nunes now
are i am not in pog champs three i was
in pog champs
two i was not invited to three but it
looks like it'll be a great event
so i look forward to
watching it which will be very very
exciting
david for president and kyle for vp i
cannot be president i was not born in
the united states any validity on marine
one flying over the vice president's
house
i i don't even know what that means i
haven't heard about that
biggest news is donors pulling money
from the republican party yeah i'll be
talking about that
tomorrow very uh very interesting story
all right let's go to joe biden getting
his second vaccine dose now
this was earlier today i'm looking to
get a vaccine myself very very soon i
mean i won't be able to get one anywhere
i won't qualify but
i'm certainly looking to get one
dose number two for joseph r biden jr
little alcohol wipe very very strong
in plunge
wipe
band-aid
[Music]
there it is
let's see if there were any comments
that they'll be able to vaccinate 50
million americans in the first 100 days
i do let me make a couple brief takes
number one my
number one priority is getting
vaccine in people's arms like we just
did today
as rapidly as we can and we're working
on that
program now i'll be meeting zoom
call with my team a little later this
afternoon
i have uh and i've put together which
i'll be announcing on
thursday laying out the plan the cost of
how i want to proceed the cost of what
we have to do we will cover that live
the entire covent uh operation up and
running
three to four thousand people a day
dying is just beyond the pale
yeah it's just wrong and we can do a lot
to change
it number one it's going to be hard it's
not going to be easy but we can get it
done
and secondly wearing this mask socially
distancing
and making sure people are washing their
hands on a regular basis
is critically important all right so
nothing particularly groundbreaking but
let's look at the latest on vaccine
distribution
uh more than 26 million shots have been
given globally
globe globally okay the u.s has
administered 8 million doses
and then when you look at the numbers
here in the united states
the u.s has so far used 36 percent
of the doses that have been distributed
and from the standpoint of who is used
the most west virginia
and the dakotas now these are you know
very small states
much easier to do states that are
lagging
are in terms of actual states alabama is
at the bottom
they've only used 20 of the doses given
it's been over a month it's been five
weeks or something like that at this
point
uh or no four weeks i believe nevada
georgia alaska louisiana sort of towards
the
bottom all right so it's not going well
at all it in fact
it's going disastrously poorly uh and we
have to figure out how to get these
vaccinations going
more and more quickly all right let's
get into um
do you want to do hold on what was this
this was nothing
do you want to do the nancy pelosi
interview where did the nancy pelosi
interview go
oh hold on i'll have to find it so nancy
pelosi
gave an interview to 60 minutes and it's
it's quite interesting there's a lot of
cringe
in it um nancy pelosi 60 minutes
or do you want to do the sort of um
what would we call it i guess we would
call it the
kind of low brow song that we have
which i'm glad to do just to get it out
of the way but i do want to look at this
nancy pelosi interview a lot of people
have asked me to look at it
let's see here there is that we'll just
do the song real quick and then we'll
move on okay
so this is a this is a funny new song
from jethro bradley
um this is basically com it's this is
very low it's toilet humor but we're
just doing it
this is combining the trump massive
dumps meme
with a reporter who was talking about
donald trump discharging his duty
and that's d-u-t-y but it was all put
together like this take a look 40
of the cabinet members who basically say
this is a president who's unable to
discharge his duties
civic duty and i'm proud to do it number
two
now some you have to be rough some you
have to be nice you're very long duty
came in pretty big the helicopter and
gave away garage to the kids
and it was nasty it was one of the
nastiest they say
we have done an incredible duty people
came to washington
to
[Music]
this is a political thing and every time
i say this is unfair let's go to court
they say sir you can't go to court this
[Music]
it is what it is
[Music]
i don't know what's going to happen i
hope it's not going to be a very long
trial but i'm going down
[Music]
yeah all right so that's a hot new track
from jethro bradley it's it's pretty
base i understand that
um but i figured that that we would just
debut it
um relatively catchy yeah very much so
okay so i want i'm gonna get into the
nancy pelosi interview this is pretty
interesting stuff people have asked me
to review it but before i do that
let me just say thanks to a few other
folks who grabbed
memberships on my website i don't want
to miss anybody david sperling
has signed up adrian labelle
gemma hodgson christian stafford
kayleen cavelli and tara johnston have
all signed up today
uh putting us at 17 and yeah so we've
actually gotten special dispensation
the coupon code better 21 is legal
it is legal for everybody who's been
worried about that it is completely and
totally
legal um okay let's see
casey bates says i missed their super
chat
did i catch mike pompeo talking at voa
earlier the level of hypocrisy was
astounding considering recent events
i did not i apologize i did not
um i will i will look into that but i
have not seen that all right let's get
into this nancy pelosi interview she was
asked about impeachment she was asked
about
removal let's take a listen january
6 should have been a day of ceremony
when congress met in joint session
then opened and counted electoral votes
for president and vice president
instead it will be remembered as the day
an angry mob
stirred up an aim down pennsylvania
avenue
by an election-losing president smashed
its way
into the capital leaving five dead
the building ransacked an american
democracy
under siege on friday we joined house
speaker nancy pelosi at the capitol
where her influence in the nation's
leadership is growing
as president trump's power support and
relevance
dissipates okay here we go the story
will continue in a moment oh boy oh here
we go
madam speaker who is running
the government of the united states we
have a pandemic
we just had this horrendous act of
violence
up here we had a russian hack
of our institutions is anybody running
the executive branch
of the government who is running the
executive sadly the person who's running
executive branch
is a deranged unhinged dangerous
president of the united states and only
a number of days
until uh we can be protected from him
uh but he has done something so serious
uh that there should be prosecution
against him so far so good
i gather that the 25th amendment is off
the table
that isn't nothing is off the table
the mayhem at the capitol started early
afternoon on january 6
with the rioters barreling past the
barricades
clashing with police and breaking into
the capitol
as they swarmed through the halls the
speaker was
on the house floor during the count of
the electoral college vote
oh look so tell us what happened
when when the protesters were trying to
get in here
you're up there well the when the
protesters were making the assault on
the capitol
uh before they even got to really
shouldn't even be calling them
protesters
these stores the uh capitol police
pulled me
from the podium and i was concerned
because i said no i want to be here and
they said well
no you have to leave i said no i'm not
leaving this no you must leave
police guns drawn held the invaders off
the house floor
but over in the senate the trump
supporters were able to break into the
chamber
the scenes can you imagine looking to
watch i think there was
uh universally accepted that what
happened
was a terrible terrible violation
of what of the capital of the
the first branch of government the the
legislative branch
by the president of the united states
the mob
was free to roam the halls one group
making it
right up to speaker pelosi's suite of
offices
this store they broke down as you can
see oh my goodness they broke that down
look at that they broke the door they
smashed it
and went through to another door behind
which pelosi's young staff
coward terrorized the staff went under
the table
barricaded the door turned out the
lights
and were silent in the dark under the
table onto the table for two and a half
hours
wow during which time they listened to
the invaders
banging on that door as you can hear on
a recording from one of the staffers
phones
unbelievable check this out we are
inside nancy pelosi's office
across the hall a group broke into the
speakers
so this i mean every one of these people
hopefully has been or will soon be
arrested
private office oh wow oh wow
you see what they did in the mirror
there the glass was all over the place
they took uh they smelled computer and
all that stuff
but uh laptop and then the the desk that
they actually were at
was right there that they this guy has
been arrested as far as i recall
shamed in that way but feet on the desk
and all that
that man was arrested on friday
and the fbi is investigating whether any
of the agitators
some seen in ballistic vests with zip
ties
intended to kidnap or kill legislators
or their staffers they were coming
to find you maybe to hurt you i don't
know
the evidence is now that that it was a
well-planned
organized group with leadership and
guidance
and direction and yeah and for people
who are asking what what
this super chat says do you feel it's
possible we're see we will see more
right-wing terrorism on inauguration day
yes i fear that we will i fear we will
direction was to go get people they were
vocally saying
where's the speaker we know she has
staff they're here someplace we're going
to find them
[Music]
while all this was going on speaker
pelosi and senator schumer
from an undisclosed location called on
the president to tell his followers to
leave the capitol it was a landslide
election
and everyone knows it especially the
other side
or especially but you have to go home
now we have to have peace
president said go home but the election
was you know you know went on with his
lies
his misrepresentations his delusion that
he won
a landslide in this election so finally
the protesters were rejected and you
came almost right back
into session how did that happen i know
from chuck schumer
and from mitch mcconnell there was
consensus that we should come
there was no there were some suggestions
that it may take too long and we should
do it at the undisclosed location
but there was general beliefs that from
the message of strength that we needed
to send
we had to go back to the capitol as soon
as possible
the senate will come to order vice
president pence who had been taken to a
secure location in the capitol
concurred with the decision to resume
the count amid reports
that he was livid at the president let's
get back to work
work dragged on until almost 4 a.m
i object as republicans challenge
certified
election results and they did that after
the violence after the violence
shame on them and shame won two-thirds
of the republican caucus in the house
supporting
those so these people are enablers of
the president's behavior
i remember when republicans in the
senate went to see richard
nixon and said it's over i i actually
told
talked about this today when i talked
about the two paths forward for the u.s
and that clip is going live
in about 45 minutes i talked about
exactly the nixon
analogy that's what has to happen now
one of the reasons she's so eager to see
mr trump's immediate removal from office
is her grave concern that in the next 10
days
he might try to do something reckless
militarily
including ordering the use of nuclear
weapons i don't think that that would
told us she sought advice from general
mark milley
chairman of the joint chiefs i have
sought
information from those who are in a
position to know that there are
protections against this dangerous
president initiating
any military hostilities or
something worse than that something else
she and senator schumer did was call the
vice president
to urge him to initiate the 25th
amendment
that provides procedures to remove a
president from office
we were kept on the line for 20 minutes
he was going to be here in a minute a
minute minute
well he never did it kept you on hold
for 20 minutes at least
of course i was i was at home so i was
running the dishwasher putting my
clothes in the laundry we're still
waiting for him to return the call
joseph r biden jr of the state of
delaware has received 306 votes
donald j trump of the state of florida
has received 232 votes
after congress confirmed joe biden's
victory in the election
president trump read from a teleprompter
offering his most conciliatory statement
about the election and now remember this
was totally forced
and he didn't mean any of it and within
minutes went back to tweeting lies about
voter fraud which culminated in him
getting suspended for life
uh from uh from twitter frustration will
be inaugurated on january 20th
my focus now turns to ensuring a smooth
orderly and seamless transition of power
now that he's burned the house down he's
promising to throw the matches away mr
trump has said he will not attend the
inauguration
the new president has said he wants to
turn over
a new page of bipartisan cooperation
in the election in november
someone said that the uh
the mandate that the democrats won
was not about issues because you lost so
many seats
that the mandate was so now i think
pelosi starts to get a little irritated
for tone and attitude
and a strong desire for compromise i do
know
that it was a mandate uh for us to go
forward with an agenda
for america's working families as well
as to do so in tone
we have i always say to our members we
have a responsibility
find common ground
when we can't we must stand our ground
but we have to
we have a responsibility to try you
yourself
are not known as a person who
compromises here we go
no i am uncompromised we want to get the
job done
i'm mischaracterized by the republicans
that way
but that's a tactic that they use no we
don't know we want results for the
american people what about the covert
relief package
yeah that was held up for eight months
no
but so there are a lot of criticisms of
pelosi
i don't think the covid one is a good
one because
by april may democrats did already have
another proposal
so i don't think this is a good line of
attack but it leaves nancy pelosi sort
of agitated about the next part that was
their obstruction i understand this oh
wait
was there obstruction yours their
obstruction
no yours too no it wasn't obstruction
you've held out for eight months
no we held it up because there was no
no respect for our heroes our
state and local health care workers
police and fire our first responders
our sanitation transportation food
workers our teachers our teachers our
teachers they would not go down that
path there's a member of your caucus
who said specifically that we look like
obstructionists and it was a mistake
well i don't remember anybody saying
that and they may have and they may have
but it isn't it wasn't a mistake and i
would not
and nobody expects me to to support
something
that solidifies injustice in our country
let's talk about the russian hack
there was an invasion a cyber invasion
big deal
big deal what should the united states
do
about that in terms of the hack that the
president would not
assert his authority first of all
uh he hasn't said anything no he hasn't
said anything except that
maybe china did it yeah well the the
president again has
a 10-year blind spot and whatever
obligation i don't know
what the russians have on president
trump whether it's personal
whether it's political whether it's
financial i don't know what it is
you think they have something on them
but there's no other explaining
why this president united states so i
think the part that's problematic here
is that trump's reaction to the russian
hack was pathetic and you know maybe
china did it we know
we don't know china didn't do it's like
well we don't have evidence um
i think it's nuts i think trump's
reaction has been nuts but i think the
problem we're
democrat and we'll see if in the last
minute or two here she cleans it up
is democrats have to explain what they
want to do
because very often they will just sort
of frame themselves as wanting to take
action but it's never clear what they
what does it mean to
stand up to putin are you threatening
war what kind of war are you talking
about you know so i think that the the
problem is often that there's this
uh rhetoric that's applied and it
focuses on how trump hasn't stood up and
of course that's true
but what exactly is it that you're
proposing be done
is such a handmaiden of
can we talk about the a word what's that
age oh age okay so now i think this is
what pelosi liked the least
you're 80 right you're number two steny
hoyer is 81
you're number three jim clyburn is 80.
uh why haven't you brought young people
into the leadership because we have you
perhaps don't know
why does aoc complain that you have not
been grooming
younger people for leaders i don't know
you'll have to ask her
see so that she's clearly irritated at
this point because we are
that was kind of sharp kind of
dismissing her i'm not dismissing her i
respect her
i think she's very effective as are
other or many other members in our
caucus that the press doesn't pay
attention to but they
are there and they are building support
for what comes next the speaker intends
to keep the pressure on
president trump to leave office as soon
as possible
if he does not resign immediately she
has threatened to initiate
impeachment proceedings what if he
pardons himself
what if he pardons these people who are
terrorists on the capitol
okay i like calling them terrorists
that's good or part of
he does that he can only pardon himself
from federal offenses he cannot pardon
himself from state offenses and that's
where
he's being investigated in the state of
new york
there is a possibility that after all of
this
there's no punishment no consequence
and he possibility it's almost a
guarantee run again
for president and that's one of the
motivations that people have for
advocating for impeachment
won't that take more than the 10 days i
mean does it actually make sense
well i like the 25th amendment because
it gets rid of him
he's out of office but there is
strong support in the congress for
impeaching the president a second time
this president is guilty of inciting
insurrection
insurrection uh he has to pay a price
for that
so there it is i mean it is it's an
interesting interview a lot of the stuff
is pretty milk toast
there's some interesting elements here
and of course
i completely 100 agree uh
that trump should be removed impeached
whatever doesn't really matter how long
it takes part of it is about preventing
him from being able to run again so
there's a lot there and a lot of really
really important things
um people asking if i'm gonna play the
arnold video
i'm open to playing the arnold video
it's a very good video
it's a very good video i'm open to
playing that you know one of the things
i was thinking of
um oh if someone could help me find i'm
actually having trouble finding it i was
looking for it while we were listening
to that
the the breakdown in security was so bad
at the capitol
that the the people didn't really seem
to expect
to be in for very long and you could see
that because
once they went in and they got in they
sort of like didn't know what to do
they were just kind of like wandering
around and many of them didn't didn't
know what to do
and what i found interesting is it it's
sort of like what happens when i get a
troll caller but i just allow them to
talk to me
they imagine that i'm going to rush them
off the air right away but of course i'm
fascinated
by these troll callers so i'll just talk
to them and there was one when the
kansas troll
called in and he started saying are you
going to start selling
supplements like alex jones hatred
supplements
and i just can't kind of handle it like
no no no we're not going to sell we're
not going to sell any supplements
and the guy expecting to be taken off
the air right away
immediately collapsed and it was it was
just hilarious
and i feel like that's similar to what
went on with a lot of these protesters
who the
the failure was so bad that they broke
in they broke down the door and all this
different stuff
then they were like now what do we do
and some of them started destroying
property some of them were just kind of
wandering around
it was all um it was it was all
relatively
bizarre and um
okay that's that oh and from from the
standpoint of voicemails
so here's just one other thing i
mentioned to you guys
that since democrats took the senate
and the armed riotous trumpest
insurrection
i hadn't heard from any of our typical
right-wing callers i didn't hear from re
peter
i didn't hear from prickles guy and i
hadn't heard from troy york
i finally heard from troy york okay i've
not
listened to this but troy york is now
back
let's see what his subject is now that
we're hearing from troy york again
hey dave uh yeah i'm watching a
little youtube tonight and uh i see the
hodge twins uh
again these hotch twins i don't know who
these people are but he seems very much
engaged with them
uh they've been putting out some good
daily programming uh
unlike your propagandist uh globalist
pro globalist program globalist code
code for jew here okay
and uh they've been doing some good
programming about this uh
the capital the storming of the capitol
building
and uh i think yeah i believe uh
a small group of antifa far left
radicals
infiltrated the overall larger rally
yeah of course there's no evidence of
that and uh when you see on
video uh hundreds if not thousands of
people participating
even if you want to make the case that
somehow
antifa triggered the event there's a
whole hell of a lot of people stupid
enough to follow the lead of antifa now
that's
if and of course the truth is there's no
evidence of that whatsoever
um they gathered at a certain point yeah
i believe it was like pre-arranged it
was definitely pre-arranged
by trumpists uh by the democrats and the
far left
socialist wing of the government which
doesn't exist there's essentially no
socialists in american federal
government
to let a few of these radicals in
actually into the
um double agent protesters
into the capital and to be used the
capital
against uh repressing patriots and uh
trump supporters
and it's like it's hard to it's so
stupid and so obviously unbelievable
that it's hard to even get too worked up
about it i think that if they were
really domestic terrorists or that these
politicians
were actually in danger and if these
were domestic terrorists
they would actually be dead i think this
is another
well that's actually very dangerous i
mean it it was
thankfully they got out quickly enough
and they were only lightly armed
um but that's uh that that seems to be
what this guy is suggesting would be
better in some way i mean it's very
dangerous
you know we have this guy's info maybe
we should provide it to the fbi
false flag fabrication of the democrat
party
yikes and uh don't believe a word of it
i think it's all total more horseshit
more horseshit from your political
spectrum
yeah i mean it's just like you know my
my people aren't violent none of us are
violent
you manipulators of the democrat party
oh the left manipulated these people
into committing crimes i see
to take
a organized protest and then redirect
a false narrative yeah so anyway
that's going yeah that's going to the
fbi and that that seems uh
i mean that's very very uh very very
aggressive and and
dangerous to me okay so
i am going to do some of the no-fly list
videos people have been asking me to do
no flyless videos and i do want to check
these out we're going to check them out
um momentarily now can someone confirm
this one where a guy is taken down and
yells you're treating me like a black
person
i've been told this is actually an old
video
and that it's not actually new can
anybody confirm that
because this has been going around and
i've been told that this is this
actually has nothing to do
with the last week it's from 2018. okay
yeah so we're going to be we're going to
be skipping that one
anyway i'm going to get back to that in
a second before i do that i want to say
thanks to
oh geez nobody nobody is signing up on
twitch that's sad
but i do want to say thanks to the
people who signed up on my website
joinedpakman.com thomas humpquist
humpqvist
is a new member daniel aguilar is a new
member
arvid riddall
florina tennyson
mike smith and troy tennyson who looks
like a family affair
mike robles and daniel tuba singh
are very very much appreciated which
puts us at 25
a shocking number of just massive dumps
of memberships are coming in
let me look at just a couple of the um
super chats and then i want to get to
the no fly list videos
nothing says personal responsibility
like right-wing lunatics holding a
violent insurrection and then blaming
antifa yeah basically
do you know about the armed protest
advertised on posters for three days
before the inauguration in all 50 states
yes
i saw that uh david could you share your
thoughts on gavin newsom do you think
he's getting a bum rap
i don't know enough to say i don't know
enough about gavin newsom to comment
substantively
they are conservative african-american
twins that have a youtube station they
used to do comedic workout commentary oh
is that the hotch twins
that uh that guy was mentioning okay
yeah i don't know
does convicting trump in the senate
after the inauguration thereby
preventing him from running for future
office make him a political martyr seems
risky to incite these people
no it's the right thing to do i'm sick
of this whole thing oh it'll it might be
divisive it might trigger some people it
might fire people up
no absolutely not oh people are saying
twitch subscription
is broken that has never happened is
that true i've never
no hold on somebody just signed up
weird people asking how long how often
i'll be on twitch i've been on twitch a
couple times a week for a year
yeah okay all right very good let's go
to so so here's what's going on
no fly list videos are happening these
are reportedly reportedly
um folks who are getting no-fly listed
because of their involvement with
the riots but i don't actually know that
that's what all of these are
like for example this video is from
2018.
um okay here's one where people were not
allowed on let's see what this one is
about
this is what happens man this is work
this is what happens guys this is crazy
it's crazy where this freaking country's
turned into dude
yeah i mean so you know it's unclear
which what
what some of these are uh let's take a
look at uh here's one other
[Music]
it's just not clear to me that these are
actual rioters from last week
it's very very much unclear um here's
another one
[Music]
i don't know i mean it's it's all weird
um
i wish we knew more about each of these
one of you
but this is what they do the ones
they told me and they want to [ __ ]
rule yeah these could really be from any
time
um
here's another one
right now
[Music]
this one is one of the trump is getting
himself arrested
um let's see if we have any others
well a lot of cheering going on there um
let's see if we've got maybe one other
one
or you will not reborn
have a good day
why do they have to take their mask off
i don't understand why the mask comes
off
[Applause]
[ __ ]
all right we're gonna get away from this
because it's it's just not completely
clear to me which ones of these are
actually from
from the this they're very entertaining
but it's like if this is someone getting
kicked off months ago for no mask or two
years ago or whatever i mean it's
it's all kind of a kind of irrelevant i
don't know i don't know what to tell you
about that
okay uh let's see here i um
want to
oh hold on subs do seem to be working
because a whole bunch of people just
signed up 24 people just grabbed twitch
subs so they must be working to some
degree
yeah i don't know in any case big thank
you to martin resseth for subscribing at
joinedpakman.com kyle beach
graylin hammond nilo hainan
i believe that's a finnish name sandra
sapata ramirez wait one two three four
five
james hopp is six kyle santos
is seven and randy chavez
is eight which puts us at 57.
i'm up for some phone lines yeah i'm i'm
potentially up for uh
for some phone lines here okay a few
other super chats coming in
antifa clearly dresses up as a deep deep
deep deep cover
q anon guy with a spear keep up the
great work david
uh trump is resigning and pence is being
sworn in at 7
40 p.m eastern time that that can't be
true
uh that certainly can't be true
how do i get access to the bonus show if
i became a member on youtube can't seem
to find it under the community tab
yeah please email in about that
um other super chats coming in which one
is it the attack was justified because
people are angry or it was atrocious and
it was antifa
right yeah very well said
my friend sent in a remix for you okay
we will process
those in the order that they are
received
do you believe political affiliation
should be a protective
protected status seems to be a slippery
slope essentially no
essentially no i i think as i've said
before
i actually think religion as a protected
status is dubious because it's
self-professed
but i understand the legal basis for it
because of freedom of religion ingrained
in the constitution
political status i do not believe should
be protected you just pick what
political status
you have and you can change it the next
day and the next day and i i
i don't think so i don't think it's a
very slippery slope
i don't think it is uh okay
i tagged you in something from the state
department yeah i know we saw the thing
i i we
really don't know what to what to make
of it okay good so we've got
that just a few other things i did want
to get to some of the different things
that have been posted by
our friend aaron rupar here is for uh
congressman daryl issa
uh saying that the deaths of the people
during the insurrection
are overblown they're being overplayed
yikes let's take a listen hear that an
impeachment trial
wouldn't begin until one o'clock on
january 20th
after the president is a former
president so
a trump who cares that's not her
business would never actually happen
so what is this then is is this for show
is this uh so that he won't run again if
the reality of it with nine days left
the only question is has trump done
something if
impeachable the flow chart is really
simple has trump done something
impeachable
if yes you impeach that's it that's the
entire flowchart that it actually can't
happen
uh in terms of a trial well it's
probably similar to
shutting off the the twitter feed of
somebody
uh after no no
it's not at all like that uh after his
presidency is essentially all
over uh it's kicking when he's down it's
getting rid of
88 million people who follow and listen
to the president
uh there's no question no you're not
getting rid of them they get to keep
their twitter accounts
you're not getting rid of 88 million
people and
now that that's that's really dumb at
all that i think the liberals saw an
opportunity
a misstep by the president that they're
going to
overplay and they're overplaying it as
we speak
they're overplaying a lot of things
including
the death of these people in on capitol
hill
trump hasn't even come out and actually
spoken about the fact that
people died and it's the left that's
overplaying the fact that people died
doing during a violent insurrection
suggested and encouraged by donald trump
that's absolutely nuts um let me see a
couple of other things
from the feed um
okay let's see so oh marco rubio claims
rioters who were chanting we want trump
and wearing maga attire
are not actually conservatives these are
not conservatives
these are wackos these are nut jobs now
99
of the people that were at that protest
did not storm that capital they have
strong feelings about the election they
support the president and they were not
a part of it
but there is this element very small but
enough people to create a tremendous
amount of damage and put a lot of people
in danger
and we should be rejecting that group
not after the fact but before
and well yeah but we've got to make them
pay consequences now too right i mean if
they committed crimes
and to the extent anyone has indulged
that i think that's important to
recognize and point to and say look
this is why we have to watch what we say
and who we allow into the movement
because these are the people that can do
terrible things and they may be
they may be incited to do things by
words that maybe you didn't intend to be
read that way but they did
and that's all that matters it doesn't
matter what you meant it matters wow
that's a that's a wacky take let's
listen to jim jordan here
vice president biden to do that
president-elect biden to do that
okay um
a couple of other things that i wanted
to get to here
uh i don't want to deal with him don't
want to deal with that
no mick mulvaney to me we talked about
on the broadcast show today
uh oh okay yeah this is
so i'm starting to think a lot of the
people who talk about
1984 haven't read the book okay
because we are trying to provide a
non-partisan town square
in which people are very looks like
she's reading this
viewpoints can have productive
discussions and
force and threats of force stop those
discussions in fact they stop
thinking so it's the opposite of what we
want we want people to think we want
them to think for themselves
at the same time we strongly believe
that orwell's 1984
is a dystopian novel it's not an
instruction manual and by that i mean
that in a free country innocent people
see you know what's really weird about
that
orwell's dystopia is one where
government
essentially had all the control and here
what these right-wing nuts
are decrying is that government does not
have the control
to tell private companies what to do
it's literally the
opposite of orwell and and by the way i
mean listen you you all know i i read
uh quite a bit i i believe everybody
should
truly read there's actually three books
it's not just orwell's 1984 to get
different
versions of these dystopia read orwell's
1984
read aldous huxley's brave new world and
read we
by evgeny zamyatin those are the three
that i highly recommend everybody read
and then maybe you know don't don't
sound as stupid as this woman
that's really the main priority but
there's there's nothing orwellian
uh it's just so dumb it's it's truly so
dumb
um okay here's rudy promoting something
i don't know what that is
uh ted cruz okay i think that's
basically it as far as what i wanted to
grab from
there um okay so we're caught
up as far as that goes um
okay do so do people want to look at the
arnold video or not i've already seen it
some people are saying yes do the arnold
video
others are saying no don't do it um i
i could go either way
yeah most people are saying not to do it
yeah i mean my reaction is that it's
sort of cl it was sort of kitschy
but he says a lot of important things in
it i i don't know
um it just doesn't seem like most people
are that uh that interested in it
breaking dhs chad wolfe is stepping down
all right
another one bites the dust i think
that's a good opportunity to talk
generally about that um
chadwolf resign
four days ago chadwolf says he won't
resign
four days ago
doesn't seem as though there are news
articles about it yet
let's see chadwolf resign
latest he's resigning okay there we go
he said four days ago he's not going to
resign and now he says he is resigning
so this is from 15 seconds ago saying he
won't resign
and then this is chadwolf decided to
resign
i'm guessing he is resigning it seems
pretty clear at this point that the
articles being linked to are older
uh and here it is dear colleagues
effective hold on
effective at 11 59 pm today i'm stepping
down as your acting
secretary i am saddened to take this
step as it was my intention to serve the
department until the end
unfortunately the actions warranted by
recent events including the ongoing and
meritless court rulings
regarding the validity of my authority
as acting secretary these events and
concerns
increasingly serve to divert attention
and resources away from the important
work of the department in this critical
time
of a transition of power once i step
down pete gaynor will be the acting
secretary
blah blah blah blah blah okay so
um here's the most important message
about all of these rats
jumping the ship none of them
can be rehabilitated in their reputation
because they quit when there are nine
days left it's pathetic
it's pathetic what we've seen over the
last week is just the logical
crescendo of what we were warning people
about
in november of 2016. okay
um you all know that there were lots of
i'm not even talking about the clowns on
the right because you already know about
them
there were even clowns on the left who
back in october november of 2016
we're saying the supreme court that's
not a good enough reason to vote for
hillary
trump's not going to be that bad he's
not no he won't get away with any
authoritarianism
it'll shake things up it'll be different
it'll be anti-establishment
you know he is kind of a populist and
hillary's a corporate chill anyway so
i'm going to stay home
um come on guys come on none of these
people
deserve to be rehabilitated in terms of
their reputation
the accelerationist ideas that i just
presented were never valid ideas there's
no
historical examples from the last oh i
don't know 200 years that suggests that
that was a good idea
um and uh you know for
i don't care about party i'm not even a
democrat myself
um they they can't allow themselves we
can't allow them to be rehabilitated
after what they participated in it
simply can't happen
okay let's listen before this happened
uh chad wolfe
released a statement saying quote i have
instructed the u.s secret service
to begin the national special security
event operations
for the 2021 inauguration effective
wednesday january 13th
instead of january 19th do we know what
those operations entail
and what this actually means how is this
different from the beefed up security
that would already be in place for the
inauguration
well hopefully this will actually work
allison that is a
specific legal designation that applies
to the most high security events
in the nation ones that are likely to be
targeted by terrorist attacks and it has
the legal effect of putting the secret
service
in charge of security the fbi in charge
of intelligence and fema
the federal emergency management agency
in charge of sort of formulating a
response in case something
really bad happened so it really amps up
the planning and
and that designation was not given to
this event at the capitol even though it
was essentially
a state of the union address without the
president it was a joint session of
congress
all right so i think you guys get the
picture now they're going to take more
seriously
the security and uh we'll have a segment
on friday actually talking more about
about the security failures i'm still
i'm still researching
i do want to say thank you to the 31
people who just grabbed twitch
subscriptions at twitch.tv david pakman
let me also thank a few other people who
signed up on my website i want to say
thanks to ryan frenzel
and jill simone i want to say a big
thank you to nathan garcia
as well as ileana figuereto
and a huge thanks to don and courtney
fouts
and kevin medea
who are getting us to 94. and
yeah we're very close and i'm glad i'm
glad to open up some phone lines here
and hear from some folks and by the way
we made the official decision
for the last two months we've been sort
of piloting using discord for calls even
though we still kept our old phone
system
today i made the official decision to
sever ties
with the old phone system it's of
absolutely no consequence whatsoever to
anybody in the audience
because we've been using discord anyway
but uh
just as a little fyi we did we did make
that decision
is rubio seriously suggesting people
misunderstood trial by combat to mean
actual violence
rubio's disgusting ruby
he could mean anything
uh anything else here i want to address
haven't seen the michael moore video i'm
thoroughly enjoying the radio silence
from trump and his deactivated twitter
yeah it's really not bad
read homage to catalonia where orwell
was fighting fascists
read the prince by nicolo machiavelli
watching from south africa the coup
attempt should undermine the u.s moral
high ground when placing sanctions
on african unstable democracies very
well said yeah
absolutely a white house site did say
trump's term ended at 7 40 today posted
by a disgruntled employee
yeah it was pretty clear that was just
like a sort of a hack or disgruntled
employee
talk about rudy potentially being
disbarred yeah we'll talk about that
tomorrow
did you see angela merkel and the french
finance minister opposed trump being
banned from
twitter the aclu as well i've bookmarked
an article about that
but i have not uh looked at it yet
uh okay have i watched the voa
stream with pompeo i haven't let's take
a look at it enough people are asking me
to take a look at it let's see what it's
all about um i am i am curious i've not
seen this yet
uh it's been removed by the uploader
okay so let's see pompeo
voa hold on let's see if we can find
another video of it
one hour ago voa news
let's take a look at this
let's get to the pompeo section
presented in voice of america
which is here
[Applause]
thank you good afternoon everyone thank
you for the warm welcome
uh michael thanks for your leadership
but this incredibly
important institution bob
congratulations on returning to the helm
of voa uh i am truly happy to be here
i'm honored to have been requested
uh and it's always fun to be a fellow
tanker too uh
i want to acknowledge the tanker not tan
key i assume
other network chiefs who is with us
today steve yates of radio free asia
steve where are you at
nice to see you and a note of
appreciation too to the voice of
american journalist staff
and to all those watching and listening
i've sat down for interviews with
many of you in the four corners of the
world they have always been a joy
and speaking of which too i understand
that this speech is being broadcast on
tv
radio on your website social media and
more than so the back story here is that
trump installed a total clown loyalist
at voa
which is voice of america and uh
now all of a sudden everybody's just
thrilled with voice of america 40
languages
hats off to the translators i have no
idea how anyone can translate my talking
into uzbek this quickly
uh that guy or gal deserves a bonus
bob uh it's great to
have this opportunity i've been
following the work of voice of america
for decades
and as bob just mentioned i started my
career as an army officer patrolling the
iron curtain freedoms frontier
in the 1980s i i couldn't cross into
east germany i was serving
this guy's a joke in a little town
called bidlock
west germans couldn't cross either but
your broadcast voice of america
broadcast
could millions of men and women
whose names will never know listen to
you
often at their own peril their
governments
dealt only in lies and propaganda but
voa's listeners wanted
the truth and that's what you gave them
voa's very first broadcast in 1942 that
bob referred to began with the battle
hymn of the republic
along with i'm sorry guys just seeing
pompeo read off a prompters is was there
were there questions later what did
people want me to look at from this
because it's not seeming
super compelling or newsworthy
uh it's mostly just boring yeah i don't
know uh
he said the npr correspondent couldn't
find ukraine on a map
yeah okay this it's not seeming worth it
let me just randomly skip ahead to see
if he says anything else
that's interesting was to take this uh
this human rights project
from the 20th century that has just
fallen and fallen away
it lost it it lost its capacity
to understand the things that were
contained in our founding about how
human rights are
formed uh it had moved away even from
the universal declaration of human
rights
and what i wanted to do in that was to
reground american foreign policy and how
we thought about
human rights and i think the report
captures it pretty well
uh your point about religious freedom
and the capacity to speak freely
two two core rights that if a nation
gets
gets it wrong it will be less secure it
will be
less prosperous its people will be less
whole all right
so there's that let's see mike pompeo
people are saying on twitter that there
was something
uh important or relevant from pompeo
let's see
we cut off funding to ufn unfpa when
they kept cooperating with china's
coercive family planning system
unfpa is still working with ccp butchers
who forcibly sterilize uyghur women
disgusting
the trump administration protected life
at the u.n we launched the geneva
consensus
when multilateral institutions work
thank you wfp chief david beasley for
leading from the front
cuba's continued support for terrorism
must be stopped the us is returning cuba
to the state sponsors of terrorism list
that's relevant to hold the castro
regime it's just you know more going
backwards
with cuba uh the chinese communist party
poses a real threat
all right i i think i'm good with pompeo
for now it's like i'm look it's
it's not totally clear what i'm supposed
to be finding about pompeo so
i will uh we'll we'll come back to that
um
let's uh let's maybe open some phone
lines a little bit i do want to say
thank you
to the eight additional twitch
subscribers who just signed up putting
us at 102
and huge membership dumps happening on
the website
hans torgerson has signed up at
joinpakman.com
benjamin badou michael magaro
and guy moore have all signed up putting
us
at 106. so let's speak to a couple of
people
i'm going to get logged into my own
discord as the resignations just
keep coming chad wolf acting secretary
of homeland security just resigned
davidpakman.com discord if you would
like to speak to me
uh you can get into what is called the
waiting lobby
waiting lobby and i will
call on a few people not going to do a
ton of it today but we will do some
we've just got a very very busy week
here
at the show and just a reminder
putting parentheses on your name so that
you go to the top of the list
it it doesn't work it's just a cheap
tactic so i literally
skip over those don't if you do
parentheses i know what you're trying to
do
and it's not gonna happen it's not gonna
happen
let's go to eitan from boston to kick
things off today eitan what's going on
hello yes you're on the air hi david
yes thank you um thanks for taking my
call
so um i just kind of uh started
listening to your stream today um
i just wanted to get because i didn't i
did but
um what are your viewers anxiety on
trump denying humanitarian aid to yemen
etan with peace and love you're cutting
in and out you're it's going from
fine to to sounding disastrous where i
can't hear anything
sorry so um what are your uh
what are your views on trump denying
humanitarian aid to yemen just now
i did not i haven't seen that yet that's
news to me i would have to look at that
okay um
i've been streaming so i just didn't
come across that yet
okay um well all right well
thanks for taking my call um i love your
show
all right are you are you from israel
layton um i'm jewish but i
i'm not from israel okay very good all
right thank you for the call i
appreciate it
yeah thank you all right there is a ton
from boston
very very strong first caller as
everybody can tell
let's go next to frankie from indiana
frankie from indiana you're on the uh
on the air uh hello can you hear me yes
i can
uh hi okay um so big fan i've just
discovered your show a couple weeks ago
thank you i like what you're doing um so
i guess my question is
um looking at biden's future presidency
uh
you know there's a lot of promises that
he's
or maybe not promises but there's a lot
of stuff he said that he'd want to do
sure so he's when you know he wants to
fix the justice system
uh he talks about medical marijuana and
making it legal he talks about
immigration he talks about daca and all
that
uh me being a daca recipient
so i guess the question i have is what
do you think should be
the things that he should prioritize to
try and pass or to
pass in his presidency to kind of show
people that
you know he is a president that keeps
his promises and then obviously gets
himself probably re-elected
uh in 2024. so you've got to divide the
you've got you have to divide it into
things biden can do by executive order
and things that he cannot so first of
all everything he's promised or even
elements of it that can be done by
executive order has to be done right
away
uh first first two weeks first three
weeks uh right put it together and and
go ahead and do it
as far as the big legislative things
uh uh greens i'm calling i know he's not
green new biden is not green new deal
but he took elements of green new deal
into his infrastructure and clean energy
plan do what i'm call
what i'm calling green infrastructure
plan must do it it's
economically stimulative it's good for
the environment and it's good for
um it's good in all ways it's good in so
many ways so
that's got to be a priority making his
healthcare promises a reality has to be
a priority
um second third what his third stimulus
must be a priority he just said last
week
if we get these two seats then we're
getting two thousand dollar checks and
another stimulus got to do it
promises on vaccine must be done because
nothing's going back to normal until we
get people vaccinated
um fixing daca needs to be near the top
of the list because it's been so acutely
destroyed but
and messed up by trump but a lot of that
he can do via executive order
so um you know there's no it's a very
long list and
and the first thing is to figure out
which things can he do unilaterally and
what does he have to do
via via legislation those are going to
be longer processes
because i can definitely see uh let's
say you know in 2023 when re-election
start talks start to come back up
uh people like conservatives are people
who are a lot more progressive than just
democrats are now
using the stuff he didn't or he wasn't
able to do against
him and be like well we probably
shouldn't get him again because he's
getting old
and he didn't let's say for example he
didn't pass some
sort of green new deal thing or some
sort of
uh you know immigration thing they'll
just use it against it so i think it's
probably
really this is going to be even though
i'm glad he's you know
going to be president his president i
feel like it's going to be really really
difficult for him
in these four years well listen if he
can't if he can't get anything done with
a democratic house and senate then he's
in real trouble
uh now democrats have taken everything
great
um i i think they get crushed in the
midterms
unless there are some accomplishments to
point to between now and 2022 there's no
there's no doubt about it it's
unquestionable
and when you say hey people might hold
him accountable for the promises he made
good
that's how it's supposed to work i look
forward to that i agree yep
yeah especially because like since so
many one of the things that people
talked about is how
even though cause you know you know how
a lot of people thought that democrats
would
retain and win a lot more seats in
congress yes but they ended up losing
seats
i think that just like how you said
that's a really scary thing that could
happen where if
they don't start passing things like
even congress people have promised
right then it might just flip over back
to being let's say 50 50 where
you know you're probably not going to be
secured to have your senate seat
or your congress see for either party
absolutely
completely agree with you thank you for
the call of course thanks so much for
having me
pleasure all right very very good um
okay
let's go next to uh
why don't we speak there's a lot of
people holding right now i just want to
be up front that the number of people
holding exceeds the number of people i'm
going to talk to by probably 10x right
now
so just just so everybody kind of knows
what's going on
let's go next to victoria from texas
victoria from texas you're on the air
victoria from texas please unmute you're
on the air we'd love to hear from you
and last opportunity yes victoria you're
on the air
hi oh my god i'm actually here
you're here we're all here together
okay so um my question
is about um the impeachment process yes
um hopefully we already know that the
democrats are probably going to
like push it forward in the house but
all it is really now is about the
republicans so yes
is it so is there like a really good
chance that he could be impeached
because what happened at the capitol
you mean convicted by the senate i
i'm i mean um sorry i mean oh my god i'm
nervous
so listen let no this is fine this is a
good opportunity victoria so
it is almost it seems almost a foregone
conclusion that democrats have the votes
in the house
to impeach but remember that starts a
trial in the senate and then the senate
votes on whether
two convicts it just took a bit yeah
right
yeah i don't know the answer i don't
know the answer as to whether there
would be votes
to convict in the senate yet um i think
it's going to we're going to need to
figure that out
and in particular if the trial doesn't
happen after biden's first hundred days
i have a hard time imagining that you're
gonna get 10 republicans to say yeah
let's convict i don't know
yeah because the republicans even though
what happened there's still
like i feel like they're still
firm on trump like they don't want to
let go like they
many of them are last minute yeah
you're absolutely right but all we let's
take it a step at a time victoria let's
first see
if the impeachment happens uh wednesday
morning when they're going to vote
okay okay okay yeah okay thank you oh my
god is i
i'm willing to talk to you so yeah thank
you so much for calling in i appreciate
it
okay all right victoria's gone very very
nice
uh okay let's go next to
uh let's go to tim from scotland tim
from scotland you're on there
hi david can you hear me i can hi
really good to talk to you i've been
listening for i don't know quite a few
years now
my pleasure i i'm going to really
disappoint
the vast majority of your american
audience because i'm actually not
scottish
i could tell right away i i was about to
say you
you you lack a scottish accent acutely
yeah
i'm from the i'm from the uh southwest
of england but i i i
fled up here for uni a few years ago we
will still allow it
yeah good stuff um i have a few
questions
we can do both for one whatever um the
first one was about the capital attack
um riot interaction whatever um
the authorities as far as i can see are
still claiming
that there was no intel in like
preceding the event
would indicate that something like that
was going to happen yeah but i mean if
you actually just look online and look
on twitter the people who do
like investigative reporting that's just
not true it's obviously not true yeah
there was plenty of reason yeah
or they're completely incompetent
exactly or both
or perhaps probably both yep i agree
with you completely
have you had any more thoughts about
that whether or not whether or not we'll
ever get any information about
investigations or whether or not
they'll just continue they'll just sort
of avoid that topic
i think eventually there will be a
report put together but it'll probably
take two months and then by then nobody
will be talking about the report the
like the
the report will be old news but it makes
absolutely no sense whatsoever
yeah i mean so so i mean i did clips we
were all saying
there's a real possibility for violence
and
so the idea that there was no
intelligence is is is nuts
and i have i have a question about
covert as well yes please so
i i don't i don't know how much you're
following code in the uk but we're
wearing about as much of a mess as as
you are in the u.s
yeah our death rate is actually even
worse if you can imagine that
um it's it's pretty horrific um yeah
what is interesting though is that i
have this sort of idea
and i've had it for the last week or two
that maybe
the the the um there's some element
of of trust in government and trust in
institutions
that's having as much of an impact at
this point as the actual legislation or
restrictions that are passed themselves
and the reason i think this is because
i'm not sure if you know
but um in the uk we have devolved
governments so
scotland wales and northern ireland have
their own governments
that have that have power over some
parts of
of governing the country yes um
and so in scotland here we have a first
minister who is
overwhelmingly popular i mean her
approval ratings are
are huge um and scotland is faring
not great but much better than england
certainly
certainly and one of the theories has
that have been
positive and i think is probably true is
that the communication from the scottish
government
is just infinitely better than from the
morons working for boris johnson um
and whether and i think at this point
people just don't trust
boris johnson i mean no one i don't
think anyone ever trusted
donald trump and you know once you erode
that faith in individuals and in
institutions
trying to get people to actually obey
you on quite significant part
like limitations of personal freedom
like don't leave your house for anything
except shopping
is is difficult to do it is indeed i i
did you have a question on that
or it was just more of a clarity i
wondered i wondered what you thought
about the idea that like trust might at
this point be as important as what
legislation or
100 actually putting in place 100 and
that will be part of uh here in the us
joe biden replacing trump
will there be credibility from the
federal government on on covid and
i hope the answer is yes yeah hopefully
i hope
well vaccine distribution is going okay
here
but i think the next few months are
going to be super rough yes yes and here
in the us it's a disaster listen i
appreciate the call
thank you so much i thank you so much
and thanks for your work as i say i've
been a big fan for for many years and my
partner has just started listening
and i know she's listening right now so
uh shout out to her as well
all right shout out to her thank you
very very much uh appreciate that
really strongly let's go next to
rain from new york city rain from new
york city you're on the air
hey can you hear me yes i can hey how's
it going david
it's going it's going well i would say
okay that's good
um i just wanted to ask you about so i
live in nyc as you saw and a few hours
ago cuomo
tweeted something that just kind of
really confused me that he's
hello yeah can you hear me yeah you
completely cut out
cuomo tweeted something that what uh it
really kind of confused me i posted it
in chat
he said we simply cannot stay closed
until the vaccine hits critical mass
the cost is too high we will have
nothing left to open we must reopen the
economy but we must do it smartly and
safely
and i'm wondering uh how exactly he
would
plan on doing that at this moment in
time that i have no idea that would be a
question for him i don't know what his
plan did
plan is well all right i just wanted to
see if you had a comment on that
all right no i know i i've not seen that
but i would like to see
um i would like to see what what his
plan is reign from new york city thank
you very much
uh let's go next to
oh uh i don't know let's go to kiana
from
italy kiana from italy you were on the
air oh
can you hear me yes i can okay
hello i'm glad you take my call um i'm
actually gonna go back to the covid um
discussion that the
uh guy from scotland started sure and
from what i've heard and you may
correct me on this i think i've heard
that biden wants to use
all the vaccines that he has just to
start giving everybody a first
dose right and trump however his
administration or trump himself not
quite sure was actually more interested
in
keeping some back to be able to
guarantee a second dose
yes so what are your thoughts on that
at this point because we've learned that
the timing on that second dose is a
little more flexible than we thought
uh i'm okay with the biden idea we need
to do something because at this rate
nothing's going to it's in
it's going to take eight years at this
rate so i'm okay with it and
pfizer has said that they are they can
start
adjusting the delivery schedule to
better support this idea of just getting
the doses out
out and one dose is still going to
provide
immunity in some of the people it's not
going to be 95
but it'll be in some of the people
there's some evidence that
one dose will reduce the risk of sirius
covid
dramatically and we've we just have to
start doing it i think it's the right
move
and um i i think that uh
you know start start scheduling out the
second doses when someone comes in for
the first though schedule
out the next dose and hope to be able to
stick to it but i'm in favor of it i
think it's got to happen
yeah i'm in favor of it too i'm very
much in favor i think you just need to
start getting them out
i noticed you know i live here in italy
so i noticed that you're getting out is
just really slow absolutely now where in
italy are you
i live on sardinia really island above
yes that sounds fam i i was scheduled to
go
there but then covey you know yeah yeah
yeah
okay good i'm really glad you've heard
of it because a lot of people haven't
oh absolutely you always know about
sicily but there's another island too
yeah and are you or do you live there
permanently
i do now yeah i i'm from the states i'm
from california actually
but i've lived here for about 20 years
and you i mean how did
what is your sort of like how did you
establish legal permanent residence
well i have legal permanent residence
because i married an italian
got it but i'm still only have my united
states citizenship
oh okay i understand so i vote there i
do everything from the united states but
i do not
i can't vote here for example in their
elections i'm not a citizen of
italy now do you get used to i've i've
spent
quite a bit of time in different parts
of italy and one of the things that has
been tough for me
is that bureaucratically there is not a
sense of
urgency to sort of get things done when
you just need
a paperwork piece an element of
paperwork taken care of do you just
become accustomed to that
you just become accustomed to it and
every once in a while
it'll drive me crazy yeah but you do
just get accustomed to it
unfortunately interesting and when i go
to the states when i can and hopefully
soon after this coveted thing that'll
happen i so appreciate
just all the ordinary orderly
interesting things and then people say
they do it's wonderful
in terms of the culture of sardinia
is it more associated with northern or
southern italy or is it its own thing
it's definitely its own thing oh okay
interesting in the
yeah in the history you know sardinia as
the island has been
territories of all sorts of different
places right so sardinia is very much
its own thing
yeah wow well that's it i'm i'm
scheduled to go to a wedding in italy
in september and at this point
it's anybody's guess you know it's
anybody's guess right yeah
hopefully i make it can't wait to come
back home to go back home and at this
point
who knows yeah yeah i mean it's like
listen you can do it now but it doesn't
seem responsible and it doesn't seem
super safe
no i'm not going to do it now my my
parents are older there wouldn't be no
it just
doesn't make any sense for me to yeah
yeah to
risk myself or any other person so not
going to do it
well i very much appreciate the call
kiana all right thank you very much for
taking my call
there is kiana oh sorry i thought we
were done there is
kiana from italy kiana from italy and i
appreciate very much appreciate that
um okay let's go to
joshua from texas joshua from texas here
on the air
hey david can you hear me yes i can hi
um yeah so i just had a question so i'm
just going to preface this by saying
like i agree
private companies can make any any
decision that they want as far as
who's on their platform what they decide
to do and they can ban anybody
for it whatever reason that they want to
um as long as it doesn't violate as long
as it's not a violation of uh of
non-discrimination statutes
yeah yeah and that i completely
understand that but do you think that
maybe
removing trump from social media kind of
relegates his followers further towards
the fringes and
increases division in a climate where
we're
pretty much i don't know if i've ever
like seen as much division as we have
today and do you think that maybe these
decisions are
being made a little bit lightly in that
keeping
his bad ideas in the sunlight where they
can be
challenged a bit more would be a better
route so
the i think you are correct that banning
trump from twitter um
functionally is divisive and fires up
people on his side
i just don't think that that's the way
that twitter should decide whether
he has violated terms of service enough
times to be suspended though
i think it's much like with uh with
impeachment there is a responsibility
and a duty to impeach if the president
has done something impeachable it'll be
divisive or
they can't get it done before uh trump
leaves or
these are sort of secondary
considerations um
i think that uh obviously trump's
behavior on twitter
if it were not a president he would have
been banned long ago
and i completely agree with your
assessment it is
it is radicalizing people there there
are people who are going bonkers now and
are much more fired up and planning more
another insurrection or whatever
uh you're right you're right about its
impact but it is also
obviously the right decision for twitter
to make so
i i can only respect them for doing it i
i don't respect them for waiting until
what was it 12 days before the end
though because really he warranted
removal some time ago
right yeah okay all right thank you so
much david i appreciate you uh taking my
call
all right my pleasure great to hear from
you let's go next to david from florida
david from florida you're on the air
hey david can you hear me yes i can hey
david first off we'll say thanks for
taking my call been a long time listener
thank you hey dave i just want to kind
of continue on the conversation around
impeachment you know you mentioned it's
a responsibility of congress
and i totally agree you know they have
no that they uphold the constitution all
that so
yeah forget the chatter that folks are
saying it's not worth it
so i just kind of want to walk through
picking off what victoria said that
obviously the house has stated they have
the votes to impeach which goes to the
senate
while i think we both could agree that
the senate won't convict
i also understand through a simple
majority
that's right the senate can approve
trump for not from being borrowed from
elected office in the future
yes i want to get your stance on that
and also
furthermore on the notion that the house
may
i figure what a amendment is um censor
or remove certain
um members of congress through
supporting his insurrection that last
part i've read nothing about and i
wouldn't be able to comment but you're
absolutely
correct the senate could decide with a
simple majority where
in which case if they had all 50
democrats they would just need to find
one republican
um they could uh strip trump of his
it not only is it prevent trump from
running again but i believe it's also
prevent donald trump from
uh availing himself of his
post-presidential travel funding and a
couple of other things
and uh yes that is absolutely on the
table
okay great yeah i think that would be
something worth looking into and
something that you know i think the
general public should be more aware of
in general
absolutely heard too much more about it
so thanks for that confirmation on that
and uh lastly hey i noticed you updated
your graphic i just wanted to say hey it
looks good
i wasn't sure when you did that though
oh the logo you mean
the logo correct yes we are doing a
we're working with a really great fan of
the show who has so generously agreed
to sort of like um make
all of our different graphical elements
consistent
so we've updated the logo we're starting
to put the logo everywhere
we're we're unifying the look of
everything eventually i'll have a new
video behind me as well on my vertical
screen everything's gonna look all the
same which is it's gonna be great
cool man looks good i appreciate it all
right thanks so much for the call
thank you all right there it is uh okay
thanks everybody for joining me
that is going to do it for me today we
have a lot of streams coming up today
all the way leading up to and including
the inauguration stream
my thought is i will start at about 11
a.m next wednesday uh the inauguration
of joe biden scheduled for noon
i will plan to start at about 11 a.m
east okay
so thanks to everybody for joining me
remember to hit the subscribe button if
you're watching on youtube it's free we
are
just almost at 1.25 million subscribers
and make sure you are following me on
twitch because we are
rapidly approaching 100 000 uh followers
on twitch
we were at like 60k recently we're at 75
now it's unbelievable how quickly this
is moving
we're gonna do it and then you know that
it's going to happen all right so i'll
see everybody very soon